Allen starts off this hour in Sacramento
hey Alan how are you good how are you
sir
better than I deserve how can I help
well I'd like to thank you first of all
he kind of helped save my life in a way
you're you're too calm radio voices suit
my turbulent life a little so thank you
I'm going through kind of an ugly
divorce
I've been in California for two years
we've got here with my family I have
four kids uh I I my ex-wife took all the
money out of savings like I literally
have no furniture my I'm gonna be moving
my mother out here into in like two
months and she is going to put a
downpayment down on a house and we're
we're gonna live together I just don't
know what to do my new job has a 401k
that I haven't started yet I have an old
401k but I'm not sure if I'm going to
get the entire proceeds because you know
my ex took all the savings we're still
working on that
I was just wondering do I cash out the
401k to furnish a new house when I get
it or and I'm also going to be taking a
small loan for the new house in between
50 and 80 from what I've been working at
like I just don't know where to start
sir okay hold on yeah
I'm 45 mm what do you like right now I'm
making 50 okay how long were you married
18 years mm-hmm
I'm sorry well I can I can hear the
heartbreak in your voice and
it sounds like you've been through a
really really tough process emotionally
very touched sir
anytime someone is in that kind of a
situation it is a death of sorts
sometimes it's a real death but in this
case it's the death of an 18 year dream
marriage right but in a time there's a
death of magnitude meaning it's close to
you so it has an impact on you like this
one has had on you
it is very unwise to make large
decisions while you're in the gumbo like
for instance let's say a lady calls me
on the hair and she's been married 50
years and her husband died three weeks
ago and she wants to go buy a house with
her son I would tell her no bad idea it
could be a good idea it is a really bad
time for you to be making big house
decisions and you're going in partners
with your mommy after your wife just
know this has got bad medicine not a
chance I would not do this
here's here's the thing two days my
mother's getting up there in years she's
80 so one of you had a house and the
other one lived there but I would not do
a partnership that you're tied into and
three years from now something happens
you have siblings like I know I do I
have a sister who lives in New York town
and so she decides she wants to call a
claim on this house your own part of
this is just a messy legal thing that
you're getting ready to enter into it
could be that your heart heals and you
want to get remarried but you feel stuck
with your mom four years from now I
don't know but I don't mind you taking
care of your mom if she needs care and
if she wants to buy a house and you stay
with her for a while and care for her
and help her in the transition until the
next phase of your life opens up that's
an OK thing but going in partners and
you taking out a loan and her taking out
a loan and y'all be on the same deed I
would not do that I also would not put
money in a 401k right now I'd not put
money in anything except in a bank
account piled up or in cash piled up in
a tackle box under your bed I don't care
until
this divorce is 100% final and you know
exactly where you stand then you would
restart your baby steps okay but
anything you start right now could be
gotten ahold of by her in this
settlement and I'm not saying hide stuff
from her but I am saying you just need
to be very very liquid it's a big pile
of money covers a lot of time for you to
heal and and time for you to work
through this grieving process because
dude I can hear it in your voice this
knocked you on your back so completely I
moved out here for her because you want
to take care of her grandmother with our
four kids yeah and I have no family out
here I have no friends I feel completely
abandoned yeah but the thing to Dave is
I have two minor kids mmm still and
it'll be some Charles Taylor I need I
need a child support as a thousand a
month for everything spousal support
child support but furnitures now that
animart furnitures not that big a deal
and you don't need to cash out 401ks and
you know have all the penalties just to
get some furniture you're a single guy
again you go to a garage sale and you
buy an old leather couch and you throw
it into one bedroom apartment and you
sleep on it life's okay it's a temporary
thing this time next year you'll be set
up somewhere doing something but don't
you don't need to rush in to furnish a
whole freaking house you're a single guy
if your mom wants to furnish a house
she's buying she can do that and you can
live there and take care of her and that
would give you a safety net for
emotionally to heal but you don't need
to go in debt you don't need to be
borrowing money to buy a house you don't
need to be cashing out 401ks you don't
need to be making big decisions make it
so many small decisions as you can and
give yourself some time I went visited
my friend a few years ago who'd had a
massive car wreck when I walked into the
room you could hardly recognize him he
got t-boned and it smashed the whole
side of his face in end up losing one of
his eyes he was so
all over I thought I was in the wrong
room I didn't recognize him and I've
known the guy for 15 years and that's
what you sound like
it took him a little while for the
swelling to go down it took him a little
while to recover from that car wreck it
took him a little while to not flinch at
every stoplight it takes a little while
to heal from a major car wreck and
that's what you're going through man
give yourself some room don't make major
decisions in the middle of this don't
buy houses don't cash out 401ks don't go
get loans do go find a good local church
you just told me you're alone and
there's no reason for you to be alone
there's some great wonderful houses of
worship that will put their arms around
you all over Sacramento I know a bunch
of them and they'd love to be your
family right now
while you're hurting